hello and welcome to this video playing
maradona yeah I'd like to vary a little
bit here what else can I do I think he
plays in classical against the kings in
here maybe this is an interesting and
deviation from a usual repertoire what
quite sure what line it plays this one
okay if usually plays a rather classical
repertoire so we get the the Ottoman
line here okay let's think about it for
just a moment here Bishop f8 not be five
push up f 8 95 98 this note is seven I
think I'm I think I have to know ok not
be five can I go a six then if you place
that I think I can so let's get get this
going hmm I thought I can go away six
years there a big drawback and don't see
it okay well we can do this for a 5 and
so on the debts to not sure how much of
a problem it is though okay so Luke g7
yeah let's see for is info bitterly 524
a 5v5 96 is also
also close hmm interesting they can go
f5 for sure and yeah maybe start with
this move Knight see for Luke c8 yeah I
was also thinking about be five but he's
got Bishop a five that's rather annoying
and so let's put that here I'm not
getting something going on the Kings
side so quickly probably something
something went wrong here but I cannot
really tell what it was okay well here I
have Bishop b5 if he goes not be three
this is not not that terrible so I'm
going for this I goes back hmm that's
not a bad idea but I'm not sure how bad
Knight b6 is here I mean I the thing is
they always say you shouldn't lose your
light squared Bishop that's true but the
main thing is that you have to get get
in B form a g4 and i think i will do
that I think I'll get it in if he takes
on d 7 it's not so easy for him to
prevent you for now currently he's on it
enough but he has to move yeah I mean he
has to show some kind of progress on the
other side and that's not easy without
losing control over G form
for example for example if he moves the
Queen I will go g4 and even sacrifice
the exchange that is completely okay my
idea is Bishop the aid now getting this
sorry to cover c7 it's not so easy for
him to do something now okay he wants to
go Quincy age I don't want to trade
Queens absolutely not tough to prevent
stuff to prevent
hmm
well okay that's a good move Quincy 8's
with check also it's not not exactly
great here that end game you can go b5
immediately that's it it's a big problem
actually Queen takes or this one ah damn
time morning should before okay
yeah it's not bad it's not a bad move
I thought I mean that is pretty bad but
I think he had even better stuff if he
takes on c7 I thought that I might be
able to hold win I'm not into the astok
about it but it might might be okay if
you move so look I go pee should be
seven nights again it's not not great
but maybe somehow I know I he threatens
to check on e5 in some cases so and now
we can take the age 96 okay i fell apart
and finally here mmm yeah that was a bad
game
check that some reason not to resign
yeah okay that was black there's already
bad pretty bad yeah I don't know I don't
know the theory here that that well I
wonder what was wrong and maybe it is
wrong to play 98 before IEM has night be
five plate I never got in g 4 i'm not
sure how bad that really was i mean it's
that is that so terrible and when I got
here I I don't really believe it maybe
Quincy to Quincy eight assists it's just
a bit too too much if it gets clean
straited of course the position gets
gets very difficult that's strong and
here I didn't actually feel like I
should lose this or is he just winning
stuffy air force think it is rather
close this is a sir what I'm thinking
maybe I can somehow keep things covered
here and this is definitely losing
if I do this let's say 94 king is seven
it's still bad of course let me like
it's just sitting there trying to hook
this stuff but might not be that easy
for why to break through I might get in
G for him yeah something what's wrong
with that opening I definitely made some
mistake there yeah maybe Bishop f80 or
so i don't i don't really know it this
imitated me it threatens this and this
now i can just go there there yeah i
would need to look out of the theory
that wood line that old classical main
line here with 91 bishop d 2 and so on
is actually i think an estimated it has
a decent reputation for black actually
but it is pretty difficult to remember
all of that I mean I'm definitely not an
expert so if he beats me convincingly it
doesn't mean much but I think that many
Kings Indian players actually have lost
them focus a little bit of that line
because there are so many others that
are threatening and I'm not sure that
they know this well enough to battle a
very well prepared white player so it
was a pretty convincing victory for
white thanks for watching